dix mille doses de vaccin de pfizer sur
les trente mille annoncées par le
gouvernement ont été livrés depuis ce
lundi en moselle dans l'est de la france
comme le ministre de la santé présents à
metz vendredi et s'y était engagé un
effort particulier de solidarité
nationale est accomplie pour la moselle
d'ici deux semaines nous serons
vraisemblablement en tête des
départements où la vaccination est la
plus répandue
un effort particulier est fait pour la
moselle ça tient à la forte présence de
variants dans notre département
les vingt mille doses suivantes
devraient être livrés d'ici à la fin de
la semaine
mais cette décision de faire passer en
priorité certains départements n'est pas
vue d'un bon oeil par tout le monde avec
une population constituée de près d'un
tiers des seniors le département azuréen
concentre une importante population
vulnérable aux coronavirus et qui ne
peut demeurer dans l'incertitude et
l'angoissé dans la tente de voir son
territoire doté de doses en quantités
suffisantes
aussi je vous prie d'agir immédiatement
pour dotés de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de doses supplémentaires
là où des départements de france qui
appelle à la solidarité sanitaires
nationales dans le contexte très
inquiétant qui rencontre alors que le
taux d'incidence est au dessus des 500
cas de contamination pour 100000
habitants à nice et que les services de
réanimation sont occupés à presque 100%
dans les alpes-maritimes
seulement trois poissons de la
population départementale et vaccinés si
la question de vacciner par incidence
pose des problèmes d'ordre éthique et
remet en cause le principe d'égalité
plusieurs spécialistes recommandent
pourtant d'administrer le vaccin en
priorité dans les régions où le taux
d'incidence est le plus élevé de façon
très pragmatique si l'objectif est
d'éviter des cas des hospitalisations et
des décès on en évitera davantage en
vaccinant les territoires où l'incidence
est plus élevé que dans un territoire où
l'incidence est faible alors que la
pandémie semble faiblir ces derniers
jours sur l'ensemble de la planète
la campagne de vaccination mis en place
en france il y à un mois et demi se
poursuit
quant au gouvernement par la voix de son
porte parole gabriela talent il rappelle
que la stratégie de vaccination ne
devrait pas évoluer dans l'immédiat les
trois quarts des résidents en ehpad reçu
une injection et déjà plus de 20 % des
plus de 75 ans ont reçu au moins une
dose du vaccin
nous allons répondre à l'enthousiasmé de
nos aînés et puis par tranche d'âge
ensuite nous étendrons la vaccination à
l'ensemble des français selon le
calendrier la stratégie qui ont été
prévus et annoncés par le gouvernement
dans un souci d'égalité territoriales ce
sont donc les personnes âgées ou à
risque les malades du cog vide et le
personnel médical soit environ 8
millions de français qui vont continuer
de bénéficier des vaccins en priorité en
france ce sont près de 3 millions
d'injections qui ont été effectuées
alors que plus de 80 mille décès liés au
virus sont désormais à déplorer